star wars the force awakens adam
driver's ascent to the a-list of the
past decade has been as surprising as it
has been fascinating
the actor's awkwardly rugged good looks
certainly set him apart from the pack
but it's his fierce commitment to his
craft that garnered attention from some
of the biggest directors in hollywood
it was driver's work on lena dunham's
hbo hit girls that helped get the
attention of jj abrams
who was looking to cast a relative
unknown as the villain in his new movie
that movie was none other than star wars
the force awakens
and the role was the new trilogy central
bad guy kylo ren
abrams decided that driver would be his
kylo and he flew him out to bad robot
headquarters and straight up offered him
the part
wary aborting such a big project driver
almost passed on the choice role
luckily he took the part and became the
dynamic complex villain the next
generation of star wars fans deserved
alan rickman harry potter and the
sorcerer's stone
by now we're all familiar with the
rigorous casting search that the
producers of the harry potter's film
franchise underwent to find just the
right youngsters to portray the young
wizards harry hermione and ron
that search saw producers sorting
through thousands of young british faces
and organizing dozens of auditions
before settling on daniel radcliffe
emma watson and rupert grint for the
coveted roles and even then those faces
had to be approved by author jk rowling
herself
overall rolling had plenty of sway over
who appeared in the adaptations of her
best-selling book series
when it came down to casting the pivotal
role of severus snape
rowling insisted that the great alan
rickman was the only actor who could
play the part right
how did that film role come about for
you um
i was asked to do it uh if you've seen
the films
well it's tough to argue with their
choice it's impossible to imagine
another actor a snake
and the franchise is all the more
accessible for rickman's deeply nuanced
performance
chris evans captain america the first
avenger
there's no denying that marvel
entertainment has produced some of the
biggest and boldest superhero films
hollywood has ever seen
they've accomplished that feat by
thinking outside the blockbuster box
when choosing directors to guide their
properties through production
a habit that started when they tapped
jon favreau to helm iron man
still marvel doesn't always get enough
credit for making inspired choices in
their casting
last we forget they opened the mcu by
hedging bets on robert downey jr as iron
man
marvel made downey jump or rather fly
through hoops to prove he was right for
the job
but chris evans had a much easier time
landing the lead in captain america the
first avenger
in fact he didn't even need to audition
to score the coveted role
turns out evan's absurdly all-american
looks had already caught the eye of
director joe johnson
who convinced marvel to cast the actor
without so much as a screen test
while evans has become one of the most
recognizable stars in the world since
landing the role
his casting felt like a metered risk at
the time
one we're grateful to marvel for taking
chadwick boseman
captain america civil war prior to
joining the mcu is the future king of
wakanda
chadwick boseman was already well on his
way to becoming a star
in the years leading up to his mcu debut
he steadily worked his way from bit
parts on tv shows like fringe
you realize just what you did to me
if you're giving me some special power
that'd be one thing
then maybe i'll be special to starring
in a couple of the better biopics
produced in the past decade
don't let them get to you i won't
god built me the last those choice roles
aside
it still seemed like not enough people
knew who bozeman was
turns out that while not many audiences
knew boseman's work the right people did
including captain america civil war
directors joe and anthony russo
when marvel studios decided it was
finally time to bring black panther into
the mix
they almost instantly and unanimously
decided he was not just right for the
part of king t'challa
but the only actor who was they had
bozeman on the phone the next day
offering him the role without an
audition
[Music]
bill murray lost in translation by the
time bill murray agreed to star in sofia
coppola's sophomore film he already had
a dozen or so
unforgettable roles to his credit
throughout the 80s and 90s the legendary
funny man was delivering iconic work for
practically every film he appeared in
i'm a god your god i'm a god
i'm not the god i don't think seems
coppola was paying attention
and she was adamant about casting the
actor as the lead in her existential
drama lost in translation
she even wrote the screenplay
specifically with murray in mind
and claimed she wouldn't have made the
film if he had turned down the role
so there was no audition process to be
had
for relaxing times
it suntory time it actually seems more
like coppola was the one who auditioned
for murray
as the story goes coppola had a mutual
friend passed an early draft of the lost
in translation script along to murray
who then set up a meeting the pair hit
it off and murray agreed to do the film
only he never actually signed a contract
to that effect
on murray's word alone coppola took her
cast and crew to tokyo
and started production unsure of whether
he'd even show up
luckily for her and movie lovers in
general murray showed
he also delivered an oscar-nominated
performance that stands among the finest
in his career